For anyone unfamiliar with the 2003 hip-hop
hit, Hey Ya! by OutKast, the line “shake
it like a Polaroid picture” is repeated
over a dozen times.
The accompanying music video released alongside
the single saw the line punctuated by a bunch
of attractive women shaking recently taken
Polaroid photos, along with their various
wobbly bits, with dangerous levels of enthusiasm.
Ultimately the song went on to become one
of the most critically acclaimed and commercially
successful of the entire year, including becoming
the first song ever to pass one million paid
downloads, all making OutKast a household
name and revitalizing interest in what was,
at the time, a largely forgotten, or at least
antiquated, product in the digital age.
Unsurprisingly, executives at Polaroid were
initially quite pleased with the mention,
noting in a press release written by spokesman
Skip Colcord, “We’re very thankful for
the different brand exposure the song has
given us.”
Wanting to capitalize on the success of the
song, Polaroid got in contact with OutKast
and quietly bankrolled a number of parties
to be headlined by the group.
Polaroid deliberately avoided overtly advertising
during the events, instead simply hiring people
to hand out new Polaroid cameras to the celebrity
guests in attendance.
As Polaroid expected, the celebrities took
pictures with the cameras and dutifully shook
them during the song’s chorus, making the
brand seem just all kinds of cool with the
ever impressionable public.
Polaroid also gave the group new instant cameras
that they took on stage during events, notably
the Grammy’s and an appearance on Saturday
Night Live.
With people once again interested in Polaroid
instant cameras, there was just one more thing
the company had to do- ask them to not do
the one thing everyone associated with their
most popular product.
You see, shaking Polaroids is a great way
to increase the odds of the photo you just
took getting ruined, though most of the time
this fanning will do nothing at all.
As explained on a now defunct version of the
official Polaroid website: “The image develops
and dries behind a clear plastic window and
never touches the air, so shaking or waving
has no effect.”
In a nutshell, the image is sandwiched between
layers of plastic, so shaking the photo after
it is printed and still developing can actually
damage it, causing small blobs or blotches
to appear.
For anyone wondering exactly what you’re
supposed to do with a freshly ejected Polaroid
picture, according to the people that make
them: “The best way to ensure a perfectly
developed image is to simply lay the picture
on a flat surface immediately after it exits
the camera.”
Given this, you might now be wondering why
it has long been a common practice to wave
Polaroids back and forth in the air directly
after you take a picture- something that no
doubt ultimately inspired the lyric by OutKast.
This practice has its genesis in the early
models of Polaroid cameras, particularly those
that used packfilm, otherwise known peel-apart
film, where you had to physically peel apart
the positive and the negative after the photo
had developed.
Polaroid themselves notes, “Peel-apart versions
of the film needed to dry before it could
be handled, so waving the photo helped it
to dry more quickly”.
Given the design here, waving with peel-apart
film didn’t risk blotching as with subsequent
generations of instant film developed by Polaroid.
That said, it should be noted that such waving
wasn’t actually necessary even then.
One could just leave the photo to dry naturally.
However, in the 1970s, Polaroid introduced
their third generation of cameras, such as
the SX-70, among others, that used a new,
and now iconic, square format integral film
where shaking, or really doing anything at
all but waiting for the picture to finish
developing, was entirely unnecessary- everything
was contained in the film, with no need to
peel or dry anything.
Despite this, even after Polaroid improved
their instant development process, people
continued to shake the Polaroid pictures back
and forth in the air until the picture finished
developing, seemingly blissfully unaware that
this is entirely unnecessary, and even potentially
counterproductive to the ultimate successful
development.
Though Polaroid never released any official
figures related to sales after the release
of the song, it apparently wasn’t enough
to save the company.
They had to declare bankruptcy in 2008 and
were rebranded the Polaroid Corporation later
that year.
This marked the second time in the same decade
the company did this, having declared bankruptcy
in 2001 as well.
Despite these setbacks, they still produces
instant cameras, among other product, which
continue to produce photos that some people
shake for no particular reason.